right 10 a.m kickoff in cleveland well
the henderson
events center is taking shape faster
than anyone expected
the construction team is already two
weeks ahead of schedule as they build
the historic arena on the south side of
the valley
john treach stepped foot on the fastest
moving dirt in the valley
to see the vision of center ice deep in
a hole in henderson yeah it's a
great feeling growing up i would have
never seen
two hockey teams come to vegas so very
thankful to be a part of it gage quinney
is the first truly vegas-born player to
make his nhl debut
now he'll get to refine his craft where
the desert meets the hills
and where state-of-the-art minor league
facilities meet green valley parkway
usually all the henderson people have
traveled to summerlin or under the strip
to go watch sporting events and now they
have their own
convention center right here we still
have everything for them so i'm excited
for it
the construction milestone of pouring
concrete was celebrated today
sure there were politicians in pictures
but there was also progress
goals are being reached to build an
arena where goals will be scored
to be asked to be able to be the first
head coach for an inaugural season
coming up with them
in henderson here is quite an honor but
it's still an opportunity that
you know being positive and
understanding and and
what this is going to mean for this
community it's a franchise that above
all else
exceeds expectations and before you know
it
18 months from now we'll have the
henderson event center will be complete
and we'll have the american hockey
league playing its games with the silver
knights
plus a lot of other great events at the
facility to call the organization
groundbreaking would be an
understatement because they're already
pouring the concrete
john treach 8 sports now